نعلم جميعًا أنه من المهم أن نحافظ على
رطوبتك ، لكن دراسة جديدة تقول إنه يمكن
أن تكون في الواقع منقذة للحياة ، نظرت هذه الدراسة
إلى أكثر من 11000 شخص على مدى
عقود من الزمن ، وقد أجروا اختبارات الدم لمعرفة
مدى رطوبتهم ، وهنا
كانت النتائج الأشخاص الذين كانوا  ليسوا
رطبًا جيدًا والذين كانوا في الطرف الأدنى
من الطيف لديهم 21
خطرًا متزايدًا للوفاة المبكرة وما يصل إلى 64 في
المائة زيادة خطر الإصابة بقصور
القلب والخرف ومشاكل أخرى
الآن في كثير من الأحيان يسأل الناس عن كمية الماء
التي أتناولها  تحتاج إلى عدم وجود إجابة واحدة مؤكدة
لأن الكثير منها يعتمد على حجمك
سواء كنت تعيش في مناخ حار
مقدار التمرين الذي تمارسه ولكن
هناك بعض الإرشادات التقريبية ، لذلك دعونا
نلقي نظرة على النساء التي
تقول الأكاديمية الوطنية للطب حوالي تسعة
أكواب يوميًا للرجال حوالي 13 كوبًا في اليوم
، يواجه بعض الأشخاص صعوبة في الحصول على هذا القدر من
الماء ، لذلك دعونا نلقي نظرة على بعض
النصائح ، نصيحة واحدة هي الاحتفاظ بالماء بجوار سريرك ،
يمكنك شربه قبل الذهاب للنوم.
تزلج عندما تستيقظ أيضًا إذا كنت
تشعر بالجوع بدلاً من تناول الطعام ، فحاول أن
تشرب كثيرًا من المرات التي يخدعنا بها أجسامنا
وتعتقد
أننا جائعون عندما نشعر بالعطش أيضًا ، كما أننا نحصل
على الكثير من السوائل من خلال الأطعمة ، لذلك أنت
يمكنك تناول الأطعمة التي تحتوي على نسبة عالية من الماء
مثل البطيخ والعنب والجزر
الآن ، ليس من الضروري دائمًا أن تكون المياه
التي تشربها ولكن ضع في اعتبارك إذا
كنت تشرب الكثير من العصير أو الكثير
من الصودا فهذا كثير  السكر عليك
أن تكون حذرا بشأن ذلك